[音楽]
周りの人に頼みごとをするとき
なんか悪いなって思うことありませんか
相手の迷惑になる
申し訳ない
相手を利用していると思えたくないか
仕事が出来ない人間だと思われたくない
私も人に耐えることが苦手ですのでこう
いったポ気持ちがよくわかります
私の場合は6年前
人生最大のチャレンジに直面したときに
助けてくださいっていう言葉を口にする
ことが非常に難しく感じました
6年前
15歳の時に祖父の病気をきっかけに家族
でアメリカから日本に引っ越しました
移住した当時は日本語はカタコト枚柄も
読めず
前授業が日本語で行われる中学校に編入学
しました
そして入学して半年後には高校生になると
いう状況でしたのでその約6カ月間で方向
性レベルの日本語能力を習得する必要が
ありました
この状況では学校の先生方や日本人の母の
助けを求めるのが合理的な行動だと思い
ますか
私はこのチャレンジにあたって
人に頼りたくない自分の力で日本語を勉強
したいっていう気持ちが強かったです
それは自分が日本語を話しないことに関し
て自分のことを責めていたからだと思い
ます
実は小さな頃から母によく日本語を勉強し
なさい怒られましたし母は漢字脳て練習帳
も準備していくくれていました
でも私は一生英語圏で生活することを想定
してたので
日本語の勉強は不要だと思い
母の忠告を無視していました
そして海外在住の日本人の小中学生には実
は政府から教科書が配布されるのですか私
はその教科書に触れることもなく教科書は
本田のの飾りのようにのようなものになっ
ていました
このように国と母のシーンがあったにも
関わらず
15年間
日本語の勉強をサボってきた自分には今更
助けを求める資格がないと感じました
自分がこの状況にいるのは自分が悪い
そう考えるようになりました
助けを求めたくないっていう気持ちは私の
生活の他の面にも影響を及ぼし
学校生活でもプライベートでも人に頼る雪
がなくなっていきました
わからないことがあれば自分でわかるまで
努力するべき
悩んでいることがあれば1人で解決策を
考えるべき
他人にターンとできないことはもう最初
からしない方がいい
こういったことを思ってしまい何でもかん
でも自分でしようとすることが習慣になっ
てしまいました
この誰にもタウンないという気持ちは私が
大学生になっても消えませんでしたが
実は最近になって少し考えが変わり始め
ました
今は大学3年生で今年の3月から本格的に
就職活動を始めました
この約9カ月間でスタートアップ企業を
支援する2つの長期インターンシップに
参加しました
この経験は私はこの先一生大事にしていく
と思います
この9ヶ月間スタートアップを支援す仕事
に触れることによって人に頼ることの重要
性に改めて気づかされました
スタートアップ企業は革新的な技術を活用
して新たな製品やビジネスを生み出す企業
です
就活を始まるまでは私はスタートぷ企業と
関わる仕事をしたい一度も考えたことが
なく
スタートアップや起業家の世界は偉人の
世界だと感じていました
最近話題になっているスタートアップを例
に挙げますと例えばエアプロティンシャは
4日間で二酸化炭素を使ってお肉を生産
する企業です
主くす者は走塁を使って靴用のバイオ
プラスチックを作っている企業です
このようにスタートアップは私たちが
当たり前にしている世界を大きく変える
ような技術を開発しています
それこそがスタートアップの一番の魅力で
あると私は感じています
スタートップと起業家は魅力的な存在では
ありますが実は様々な組織から支援を受け
ています
皆さん
起業家の立場になって想像してみて
ください
起業するときに直面する課題は何でしょう
か
例えばアイディアを出すこと顧客を
見つけること
資金調達をすること
これらはどれも正解です
私の一つ目のインターンシップは
ベンチャーキャピタルといった資金調達の
課題に関わる企業でした
ベンチャーキャピタルは複数の投資家大手
企業金融機関から資金を集めて
スタートアップに投資する投資会社です
私のインターン先のベンチャーキャピタル
はこの中央アジア地域のスタートアップに
投資するファンドでした
インターンの仕事としてこの中央アジア
地域の国々についてレポートを作成したり
投資家の調査企業家のインタビューなど
こういったお仕事のお手伝いをしていまし
た
そして現在も参加している2つ目の
インターンシップはスタートアップ
アクセラレータープログラムといったもの
を提供している企業です
アクセラレータープログラムは全チャー
キャピタルとは異なり
スタータップを資金面で支援するのでは
なくスタートアップの事業の成長を支援し
ます
私のインターン先の
私のインターン先のアクセラレーター
プログラムでは国内外のスタートアップと
日本の大手企業をマッチングする形で協業
を支援しています
このアクセラレータープログラムに採択
サイトスタートアップの中でサイエンス
フィクションに出てくるような
技術を商品化している企業があります
例えば体温調節を可能にするスマート
ウォッチのようなデバイスであったり
微生物の力で二酸化炭素を新しい素材を
作る技術など
このような素晴らしい技術を持っている
スタートアップでも
自分より何倍も大きい大手企業と協業する
ことによって成長するんだこういったこと
を学びました
ベンチャーキャピタル
そしてアクセラレータープログラムという
スタートップの世界で必要不可欠必要
不可欠な組織についてお話ししましたが
スタートアップの世界ではこの2つ以外に
も
スタートアップを支援している組織が多く
存在します例えば大手企業大学リサーチ
パーク金融機関公的機関などこれらの団体
は協力してスタートアップが次々と
生み出される環境を形成しています
スタートアップを支援するこのさまざまな
組織と関わる中で私はこのフレーズを
思い出しました
peaks ウェッジ
トゥリーズあちゃい oooo
子供一人を育てるには
村全体の協力が必要である
アフリカ由来のフレーズで子育てはその
子供の両親の責任だけではなく
その子供が住む村の責任であると意味し
ます
私は何かを成功させるには周りの人たちの
協力が必要だと解釈しています
そして私はスタートアップの世界は
スタートアップと起業家を育成する村で
あると感じています
スタートアップ1社を育てるには
村全体の協力が必要であると言えると思い
ます
このスタートアップの成長を支援する仕事
を経験して
私の中で瞳耐える事に関して重要な発見が
3つあり
この発見をみなさんに共有したいと思い
ます
一つ目の発見
助けが必要ない人はいない
まあ当たり前のことだと感じるかもしれ
ませんが
忘れがちではないでしょうか
私はスタートアップは人に頼らず一人で
頑張って立ち上げるものだと思っていまし
た
でもインターン中に実際起業家と話す機会
がありその中でとても印象的だったのが
アルメニア人企業すっかのなれさんとの話
でした
なべさんは金融データを効率的に収集と
整理するソフトウェアを開発した
エントロピー者というスタートアップの香
露設立者です
エントロピーのサービスはデータと
ソフトウェアという科学的なものですが
何様大学で国際関係学を専攻されていまし
た
つまり彼女は男性優位の業界にいる女性で
あるだけではなく
技術的技術的な知識がなかったダブル
アウトサイダーだったのです
それなのに起業に成功したのは信じられ
なく私は1回通してこの状況で成功できた
のかをなれさに尋ねてみました
彼女は多くのメンターからの助けや指導が
あったからと答え
友人起業家専門家こういった自分より知識
のある人の助け受け入れなければ成功は
できないできてなかったとおっしゃってい
ました
なるさんと話すことで起業家は自分の力
だけで起業しているわけではないと気づき
ました
起業家はうまくまわりのリソース
周りの人脈
周りのサポーターに頼って起業して成功し
ていたのです
今まで尊敬してきた企業家が他人の力を
借りていることに気づき私の世界観は
変わりました
こんなに素晴らしい五人の方々だって他の
人に頼っているのに私が人に頼ることに
対して不快な気持ちを持つ必要がない
そう考えるようになりました
二つ目の発見
私たちは助けを求める人であると同時
助けを与える人である
スタートアップの世界では起業家は支援を
受けてばっかりではなく他の企業間に助け
を与える存在です
若い起業家のメンターとして重要な役割を
果たし
日イベントであったりアクセラレーター
プログラムのコンテンツなどに参加されて
いる姿をよく見ます
このように企業家は助け受け入れる一方
他人にもサポートを与えています
人に頼ってもいいんだよって言われても
助けを求める一歩を踏み出しにくいと
感じるかもしれません
それは自分は誰の役にも立て葬儀ないから
とか
自分は貢献できないからと思ってしまって
自分から助けを求めてはいけないと思う
からだと思います
私もそう思っていました
でもいいんちゃんをきっかけに私はもしか
したら誰かの役に立っているかもしれない
と思い改めて周りを見渡してみました
私たちは毎日小さな形で周りの人を助けて
いませんか
電車の中で席を譲ったり
迷っている人に道案内をしたり
周りの人に笑顔を見せるのもこういった
小さな行動で人の役に立っていると思い
ます
私たちは社会の一員としてお互い助け合う
ことが自然なことなのです
そこで人に食べないと感じている皆さんも
た人を助けたお返しとして助けてもらう
ことにしませんか
そして最後の発見
私たちは私たちの社会は村の集合である
っていうことです
スタータップをスタートアップの世界を
スタートアップを育成する村にたとえまし
たが
同じように私たちにもムラが存在します
家族
大学サークル部活会社
形は人それぞれですか
私たちはこういった村に恵まれ
支援を得る機会を持っています
私も多くの村に支えられてきました
無条件に愛してくれる家族や親戚
何か挑戦するときに必ず応援してくれる
友達
そして何か失敗しても何でも丁寧に教えて
下さるインターン先の方々
私はこういった頼ることができる村への
感謝の気持ちがとても強いです
スタートアップと関わるインターンの仕事
の中で
瞳耐えることの重要性を実感しました
助けが必要ない人はいないとか他人に頼る
ことと他人に頼られること自然なことで
あるといった発見によって助けを求める事
への考えが大きく変わり
私は前より少し気楽に
助けを求めることができるようになりまし
た
そして私はたくさんの村のおかげで成長し
ていることに改めて気づかされ
このむらいの感謝の気持ちが強まりました
人に頼ることに悩まれているみなさんも
必要なときは素直に助けを受けいる
恥ずかしいとか申し訳ないという
ネガティブな気持ちではなく
助けてくれてありがとう
っていうポジティブな気持ちであなたの
身近な村に頼ってみませんか
では皆さんに考えて頂きたいです
あなたにとっての
村
は何ですか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]